de camino a Júpiter va a la Sonda
espacial europea Just que despegó con
éxito a bordo de la nave espacial
arianne 5 desde el puerto espacial kurú
en la guayana francesa
este lanzamiento marca el comienzo de un
ambicioso viaje para descubrir los
secretos de los mundos oceánicos
alrededor del planeta gigante Júpiter en
más de una década la misión recorrerá
6.600 millones de kilómetros y buscará
posibles aguas congeladas en tres de sus
lunas Europa calisto y ganímedes David
es una fase de crucero muy larga por lo
que Júpiter está cinco veces más lejos
del sol que nosotros entonces
necesitamos ocho años para viajar
Júpiter y no podemos ir a una
trayectoria directa tenemos que hacer
sobre vuelos para ganar velocidad Así
que vamos por la tierra por Venus y la
tierra la tierra nuevamente hasta que
finalmente llegamos a Júpiter
descrita como una hazaña espacial jus
intentará entrar en órbita alrededor de
ganímedes ninguna nave espacial orbitado
jamás una luna que no sea la nuestra
ganímedes en sí es una luna enorme es la
luna más grande del sistema solar es
incluso más grande que Mercurio
es como un planeta pequeño tiene un
núcleo de hierro como la Tierra
tiene agua debajo de la superficie de
hielo por lo que asumimos que en
realidad hay algo así como seis veces
más agua que en la tierra
según la NASA Júpiter posee 80 lunas por
lo que los astrónomos lo consideran un
sistema solar propio hasta 2031 los
científicos podrán empezar a resolver la
gran duda que asalta la humanidad hay
vida en otros planetas más allá de la
Tierra